many economists believe that since
resources are scarce and since human
desires cannot all be blank a method of
blank is needed so let's see so let's
look at the first choice many economists
believe that since resources are scarce
oh there's only so many resources we
don't have an infinite amount of
resources and since human desires cannot
all be indulged a method of
apportionment is needed that actually
feels pretty good to indulge means to
kind of allow allow yourself or allow
someone else to have the pleasure any
pleasure that they want and so you can't
you can't indulge all human desires that
means allowing everyone to do anything
they want use as many resources as they
want we cannot do that because we have
scarce resources so indulge is feeling
pretty good a method of apportionment is
needed well that also makes sense you
can't indulge everybody you only have so
many resources so we need some way to
split those resources to apportion those
resources amongst people and so this one
actually feels this one is feeling
pretty this is feeling pretty good but
let's just verify that sometimes I just
used this word that these other choices
right over here aren't as good so since
many economist believe that since
resources are scarce and since human
desires cannot all be verified so
verified means you know validating
proving that that you know someone has
some desire so that's already feeling
weird a method of distribution is needed
so distribution isn't bad for the second
one but verifying human desires this one
feels a little bit off and remember we
always want to pick the very first the
best choice and so a is definitely a
much better choice we're not talking
about verifying you know making sure
that we know the actual human desires
and then distributing based on it so
this seems this seems I would I would I
would rule this one right over here this
one right over here seems seems a little
off since many since since human desires
cannot all be usurped that means you're
kind of your kind of ignoring them and
and and removing them in and putting in
place different desires somehow a method
of expropriation so that's kind of you
know taking from someone a method of
kind of expropriation is needed so once
again we're not talking about trying to
usurp folks desires nor kind of a method
of taking things from folks so once
again this one feels very strange and
since human desires cannot all be
expressed a method of reparation is
needed so it is true not all human
desires can be expressed but that
doesn't seem to be a counterbalance to
the whole notion of resources being
scarce so this one already feels weird
and a method of reparation reparations
are essentially a payment to someone
because of injustice is that you've done
to them and so we're not really talking
about justice and injustice right over
here so once again this also feels weird
and nowhere near as good as choice a
since human desires cannot all be
anticipated that's true a method of
advertising so advertising once again
we're not talking about how do we how do
we communicate with people what they may
or may not want or how do we convince
people what they may or may not what
we're talking we're going against the
idea of hey we only have so many
resources and we can't give everything
to everyone so we need some way of
divvying up those scarce resources so
once again the advertising really seems
a little bit a little bit off